my way of expressing myself has always
been physical my mom told me was like
since I was little it's like if I would
be angry or happy or whatever you would
see it in in my body language for me
having a new way of challenging my buddy
a new way of pushing the limits of my
what my body can do that was the thing
that really got me hooked in flying
my name is Inga DITA and I'm a dancer
and a world champion indoor skydiver
I started dancing when I was three years
old and as long as I remember I've been
dancing when indoor skydiving came along
I found something for the first time
that I was more passionate about than I
ever was about dancing suddenly I
realized like I've just found a new way
of dancing he's just on a different kind
of dance floor the discipline that I
compete in is called freestyle but when
I'm speaking about my flying overall I
prefer to use the term air dancing
because it's not just about competing
and that set discipline it's about
creating something new exploring the
limits of what we can do in flying and I
would like to take flying from being a
sport towards being a form of performing
arts flying for sure is way harder than
it looks like the wind speeds can go up
to 180 miles an hour you have to be
strong you have to be flexible a lot of
the body positions look easy but they
actually require a lot to perform them
nicely so a split for example it might
look like I'm just resting in in that
flexible body position but I'm actually
all the time pushing against the airflow
to have control
[Music]
I don't always like the use of the word
talented because it makes it sounds like
only if you have that talent before you
even start flying you're gonna get good
I've always been like a hard worker
myself so if I really want to get good
at something I'm gonna do whatever it
takes it just depends on how much you
want it
you
[Music]
you
[Music]
like a skater has a skateboarder BMX has
a bike I just saw the wheelchair do
something fun so why not take it into
the park a Maron wheels fathering him
and I ride w CM x w CM X stands for
wheelchair motocross it's you know
taking your chair into the skate park
and hitting ramps kind of the same thing
as BMX but with a wheelchair I first
started going to the skate parks when I
was 8 years old and I've been doing it
for 16 years now the wheelchair is
definitely just an extension of my body
because skaters aren't always on their
skateboard and bikers aren't always on
their bike but I'm always on my chair so
that gives me like an unfair advantage
to just practice everywhere I go I feel
like I'm lucky that I always have my
wheelchair with me because I can just
jump whenever I want I was born with
spina bifida I've had 21 surgeries
throughout my life and I spent a lot of
time in the hospitals and yeah it would
be easy to just be bummed out on that
but I was for me I just found the
positive the wheelchairs just always
been fun and it's wheels stuck to your
butt how's that not a great time in 2008
I got the Guinness world record for the
first backflip on a wheelchair now is
that a local competition here in Vegas
called damn gym
that was a pretty cool day one of my
favorite tricks is just simple handplant
because I always loved watching skaters
do it when I was growing up and you know
watching the pros do it it just was
something I wanted to learn
[Music]
I'm very blessed to be able to do what I
love is what I'm passionate about for a
living a lot of the time the wheelchair
comes with the stereotype of you can't
do this or whatever because it's a
medical device
I just always seen the wheelchair is a
great opportunity
[Music]
when you're on the trail that long you
don't really think about how long does
it kind of take me to get to somewhere
or how fast am I going you're thinking
about don't get yourself hurt
my name is Karl Meltzer and I am an
ultra-marathoner we did 36 miles yes
pretty weekday but no one's ever been
this far in 10 days I just recently
broke the Appalachian Trail record from
Maine to Georgia at 2000 189 miles and I
completed that in 45 days 22 hours and
38 minutes beating the previous record
by just a little under 10 hours total
mileage average per day for that 46 th
will be forty seven point six the 80 is
not a walk in the park it's a hard trail
and every time I click my foot and it
goes forward it totally stresses I
scream indeed you really have to have a
team it's not just the one guy running
charoli the crew who if they're not
perfect for you then it really won't be
successful I think Appalachian Trail not
only is it very popular and iconic but
it's also very difficult now it's all
downhill and easy I am concentrating on
my foot placement all the time so two
hours goes by like nothing just because
I'm zoned I'm so now I slammed my head
into the ground a number of times and it
beats you down you have to expect that
but you can beat it too as long as you
just keep persevering and fighting
through the issues that you're going to
have the last day I ran 85 miles my body
was so amped and ready to be done that
it didn't matter really how far it was I
felt the same in my lady as I did at
Mount and my just numb at that point
really destroy opponents it's important
for people to know the 80 is a special
place and it should be protected it's a
trail for one who wants to gain
fellowship with nature no matter whether
you're running it whether you're walking
it whether you're taking ten years to do
it when you walk that trail you have a
vibe and you feel it
every year someone else's gets a little
bit faster someone will break my record
for sure it might come this year I don't
know I'm still gonna be happy because I
gave it everything I had you know I
think that's what's important
you
[Music]
the first ride is the straight wall ride
the second act is our go-kart so it's
four wheels this time
bird fits right in one of these lovely
ladies and when you do hands off
stand it up hands off sitting on the
sides signs it on the side as a whole
array of acts it's an experience you
can't prepare anything in the world too
I'm Kerry Cameron and I'm Walla deaf
Ryder and I ride for Luke Fox's original
wall of death ready I started riding the
wall of death by pure accident I used to
work with horses and unfortunately where
I was working from the place shut down
so naturally we went the job centre and
I just typed in horse rider into the
search engine and will add if rider came
up and I went down to the yard and they
have the wall boot up I knew there and
there and that was it
you do you're very dizzy when you first
learn to ride because you've got
buildings down there up to the dizziness
you have to go at least 30 mile an hour
to stay on with otherwise gravity will
just whip you straight off it's a
mixture free thing so balance speed and
I'll see a bit of stamina just lifting
your arm up it's a wave goodbye audience
is quite a feat it's a good feeling
being a female rider in this masculine
vironment it gives me a great buzz
because a lot of people when they see
you walk into the wall they just think
they're a bit of flash you know but as
soon as they see you to get on the bike
you can hear like murmurs saying oh
there's a girl on a motorbike see all
their faces light up and then after the
show all the girls they're like wow
you've got bigger balls and most of the
men but but it's great to know that
they're looking you thinking bully if
you could do it then so kind of like
you
[Music]
a Castel is a structure formed of human
people it's a human tower
castells are a Catalan tradition of over
200 years today there are over 80
different Colliers or teams spread
throughout Catalunya every two years we
have a competition that twelve best
teams will perform at the concourse in
Tarragona I'm proud to be a member of
the casteless de Villa franca the
Castella Stabila franca have won the
concludes for seven consecutive times
here we hope to make it eight
consecutive victories these are very big
structures very big castles and they
require three or four hundred people at
a time to make these kind of
constructions and they can reach heights
of 15 meters
the most important thing of when we try
to make the castles is obviously the
safety of the people involved we have
very small children of the age of four
or five who will climb to the very top
of the castle everybody is working to
make sure that this is the safest
possible activity for them this is very
important because occasionally castles
will collapse and it it looks
spectacular but it's it can be very
dangerous it's quite common for people
to break the leg on arm shoulder
injuries
at the castle progresses the pressure
builds everybody is trying to find a
little bit of oxygen in the bottom of
the castle there have been times when
people have fainted or collapse but you
still have to keep going because you
have the collective responsibility that
you don't want to let the team down
you hear the final music that you know
the castle is completed if you can relax
a little bit but you still have to
concentrate because this is the most
dangerous part of it also because if you
relax too much the structure can
collapse very very quickly why am i a
castella development this is a very
complex question and I don't really have
an answer you can't explain it's
impossible to explain you have to feel
it if you feel it if you understand
[Music]
[Applause]
you